so that's a surf set workout that was
totally rad outtakes I love it
we've scoured the city for the hottest
new fitness disciplines these are the
workouts everyone's talking about
we got surf set white eyed tabata yoga
and boot camp it's your body
this is fighting to me I'm Mike and I
created Surf's Up surf set really
started out of necessity I couldn't get
to the ocean I really loved the way that
the body type and the fitness level that
I attained while surfing so I needed to
create a workout that could mimic that
this is your at-home surf set upper body
workout on this three-minute surf set
pocket workout where we working on the
upper body all these exercises you can
do a small confined space in your house
or a hotel room if you're on the road
we're gonna break it into two sections
we're gonna go back and biceps first so
first one we're gonna start with the
lateral curls to pick up your dumbbells
if you got them or you can go over
resistance bands feet should be shoulder
width apart all you're gonna do is
alternate right arm left arm and you're
just gonna bring it to that opposite
shoulder hold and pause and right back
this next one is we're gonna go right
into the lunge row okay so you've been
that right foot forward left foots
coming back sit it right into the squat
dumbbells in front and we're gonna pull
back squeeze as extend all the way back
last exercise arnold's but it's gonna be
curls it's a press okay curl up spin
right over the top back down nice little
pause in the middle yeah yeah got it
we're gonna repeat those 15 seconds each
I'm gonna do it two times moving on
we're gonna go into chest and triceps so
first exercise Diamond push-ups okay
bring those hands right down to the
ground feet to the back right down right
up okay
next exercise just gonna be walking
lateral push-ups so we're gonna start
almost the same position as before we're
gonna walk nice and wide out push up and
back all the way out and back and from
there I'm going to go to switch foot
dips
okay put those hands flat one foot up
dip down switch alright right nice well
let's see what you got let's give it a
shot
it's a first time around just these boom
right up to that opposite shoulder okay
yeah keeping that core tight just
focusing right on the head of the yeah
bicep there okay right about 15 seconds
from here once you walk right into that
dumbbell row okay so right in that split
squat there you go now making sure
that's true those head and shoulders are
back there you go
make sure those elbows are going nice
and high pulling back there you go from
here bring those two feet together
Arnold something yeah bring those throws
feet shoulder-width apart nice curl up
to press nice nice and controlled little
pause in the middle there you go let's
get rid of those dumbbells go right into
triceps and chest
Simon push-ups you got it take core
right down focus on bringing those
elbows straight back right along the
ribcage
now we're gonna go right into those
walking lateral push-ups yep no get out
of your way here tighten the core as
you're going down pushing through the
chest alright now we're gonna go right
into switch foot dips focus on exploding
up and kicking that foot forward and
switch triceps straight back make sure
they're nice and tight that's it other
side you got it good work yeah thanks
I'm not that coordinated I guess the
bounce spatial awareness you did great
though worked right in the middle of the
square that's what we're asking for so
recap this upper-body search network out
we're starting with back and biceps
doing the lateral curls then moving into
lunge rows finishing up with a curl two
presses fifteen seconds of each of those
so you repeat that series twice move
into the chest and triceps starting off
with the Diamond push-ups move into
walking lateral push-ups and then we
finish off with switch foot dips 15
seconds peace do that twice for a total
of 90 seconds you add both of those
things together you get your
three-minute pocket surf step upper body
workout thank you for kicking my ass a
little bit there appreciate it push it
hard work absolutely see ya ma'am all
right
be sure to subscribe so you don't miss
out on any other fighting weight
episodes